Here is Acme's vocabulary. Some of it should be similar to you from the Garland
and Shaw paper that you read, and terms that we have been using to describe
architecture so far. First off is components, these are computational elements
and data stores. Along with them come connectors, which are communication and
coordination among. The components. Ports are com, component interfaces,
possibly including protocols. And roles are similarly connector interfaces. So
you can imagine plugging together components and
connectors using their their po, ports and roles. The Acme term for
configuration is a system. It is the set of components and
connectors you have for a particular architecture you're describing,
the actual configuration specified via what Acme calls attachments of the ports
to the roles. I'll also be talking about representations, which is Acme's way
of describing hierarchical decomposition across multiple levels of abstraction.
And rep-maps which are specific bindings between those levels of abstractions.
Those seven terms constitute all that Acme
requires of you to understand in terms of building architectural descriptions.